in your opinion what do young people so
I'm concerned people under the age of 25
not fully realized about being a
Hollywood director no at section it's
interesting question I don't know I
think I mean being slightly older than
25 if I don't know if I know you know
certainly everything there is to know
about what it means to be a Hollywood
roar I think they're different they're
just different tears of it you know like
when you deal with I don't think you can
really understand how the industry works
until you get inside of it and then you
realize how many how many people are
inside of this calling the shots it's
almost like what they say about the
president you know it's like the
perception of the president is is that
he's in control and then they tell you
oh when you get elected president they
take you in a room they open the door
and they go you see these three guys
these are the real guys that are making
all the all the decisions for the
country and whether or not that's true
this certainly is an enormous amount of
politics involved in Hollywood
filmmaking that it's at a much higher
level because and then the independent
level because at the independent level
you're dealing with fewer politicians
you're dealing with fewer executives
you're dealing with a depending on the
budget and how you make your independent
movie but it's certainly if you raise
your movie independently financing
independently you're not dealing with a
army of executives that are weighing in
at every conceivable stage whether it's
the writing stage which certainly that
can be you know have you ever you know
Google Patton Oswalt's you know bit
about about what it is to be in the
development process in Hollywood and he
gives a very sort of simple and
hilarious example of what it's like it's
like at a certain point you want to take
a mitting needle and just drive it
through your eye into your brain not
because not simply because the notes are
that you're getting notes
full-stop is that often time the notes
are just inane you know like he does a
bit I can't remember I'm not doing it
verbatim but he says you know the
executive going on page three he's got
pants
but at age 70 s got a hat what that's a
problem you know we gotta you know that
kind of thing so being able to withstand
the level of inanity the level of
interference . whether the commons and
that's not to say some some notes can't
be brilliant and totally advanced a
movie but the idea that there's so much
money is at stake on a hollywood movie
that the oversight is can can be over
power and that is oversight is not the
ally of art you know going back to what
we were saying earlier limitations and
things like that the parameters and
having to fight your way within sort of
that that can be that can be the whole
necessity is the mother of invention
kind of thing but I think in Hollywood
filmmaking I think that the interference
the level of interference throughout the
entire process is that such a level that
you have to be prepared to be okay with
that level of interference in your
creativity not only okay you have to
know how to manage that and politically
you know engage and make those people
feel that they're part of the process
and not an interfere not an interfering
element and all these things and and
that's something that a young filmmaker
who has not yet stepped into that arena
may not be prepared for and and and and
in the in the times when I have done
films or for the studios or chose for
the networks and that surfaces which it
always does different and totally
different from one like say I made some
guy who kills people which was just me
and Ryan effectively making our movie it
always surprises me I always go oh
I forgot I forgot that not only did I
forget I forgot how much I hate this you
know and how I got to deal with this now
and any filmmaker who says that they
don't have a problem with that kind of
meddling and I may be meddling is the
wrong word because they can always say
look we paid for your movie so
we're entitled to meddle so don't give
me that you're not you know and there
would be right to a certain extent but
if you're
if any filmmaker says that doesn't
bother them at times is lying and you
know they have to have found it we have
to find a way to manage that do you
think that's what separates the people
that cross over from the indie world to
the professional quote unquote
is that is that ability to take the
metal here because it's that strut well
I don't want to be structured I don't be
boxed in I'm an artist I can't yeah yeah
I definitely think that I think the
ability to to make that transference if
you do get in a situation where your
independent film it's so well received
and you win all the awards and it fits
the particular genre that a studio goes
hey you know what he would be great to
direct the next alien movie you know
let's get him you definitely have to be
able to fit into that the way that
particular game is played and not just
fit but but but be a willing participant
and not an adversary because nobody
wants no studio wants a pain-in-the-ass
director who's like at fighting every
note and you know they they nobody wants
that hassle so the directors that I know
that I came up with that have done well
in that world are not only the kinds of
filmmakers that make that want to make
the kind of material that a studio wants
to make but they're also able to more
they're very talented in those kinds of
dealings and they're okay with it like
it doesn't it doesn't kill them it
doesn't doesn't doesn't break their
spirit you know I've always envied that
you know like wow you know I would love
to you know not be so hurt by somebody
changing you know my thing you know to
be okay with that do you think some
people are just born with that ability
to be to flow with it I think so I think
it has to do with I think it has to do
with your personality I think it has to
do with your upbringing yeah it's weird
I think the personality of a director is
some I mean look what does the director
do fundamentally fundament fundamentally
that's what Coppola said in in hearts
and hearts of darkness he said that the
direct director is one of the last
dictatorial posts available as a job
right
so a dictator is like do what I say you
know a dictator is somebody who you know
wants it his ways a king you know or God
so that attracts a certain control freak
personality of which I am definitely one
but how many gods are there allowed you
know I mean but but when you're making a
film for the studio's you're yes you're
like the God sorta on paper but there's
a whole bunch of gods that are much more
powerful than you that have a big big
say in what the final thing is you're
not God
you're God I'm it says directed by but
you're not God you're and if you're the
writer it's even worse you know like I'm
sure writers you know so many writers
will tell you yeah I wrote the first
draft but there were fourteen more
drafts and seven more writers before it
finally so imagine it's why so many poor
writers are like let me direct even if
they're not necessarily even even if
it's not their wheelhouse they still
want to control because they or the
illusion of control because they don't
want their their ideas diluted to that
extent so yeah I think that they're you
know and I've learned I've learned to
compartmentalize I think the way to do
it is to totally understand that in a
studio or network environment that you
are part of the controlling element but
not the controlling element and that
it's a it's a definitely a team effort
in that world and you have to be okay
with that and I am okay with that when
when I identified that this is with that
situation and I but I would be lying
also to say that I don't relish the
ultra low-budget independent experience
where even though I don't have all the
toys and the salary and any of that
stuff maybe I'm not even getting paid at
all but even more gratifying is the fact
that right or wrong I'm calling the shot
you know and it you know and it may now
work but at least it was my call is
something that I think is valuable to me
right that goes back to what you were
saying about the the masterpiece that's
up there somewhere that we all kind of
have
yeah maybe we can't make for lack of
money or whatever it is but yeah yeah
like you know like you know look at like
the documentary that was so interesting
you know Jodorowsky 'he's dune i don't
know if you saw that documentary but
alejandro jodorowsky you know the you
know the great crazy filmmaker was going
to make dune in the 70s business before
star wars and his and his documentary
tracks how he created this incredible
design and an insane you know an insane
vision and it all and for the studios
and it almost got made and at the last
minute didn't happen and many of the
design ideas and the artists that worked
on that ended up bringing those ideas
into films that did get made into ridley
scott's at Haley and HR Giger was
originally who designed the monster for
alien was originally on board for dune
so many of the conceptual artist that
created the spaceships for dune again
the movie didn't get made ended up
working on on Star Wars and so all these
sort of images and ideas that he had
fabricated that didn't find their way
into this realization found their way
into other movies and he has this book
of a story boarded it and it's like you
know it's like one of those things like
this it's so beautifully realized and
storyboard form it's like like monks has
like you know like it's that kind of
thing and Nicholas wind and Reverend who
is a friend of his is in the documentary
and he talks about how he's one of the
few people that has seen dune in that he
went over to you know Russkies house and
he said do you want to see dune and he's
like what do you mean you didn't make it
this oh but look and he brings this dune
book out and he goes in Arras he tells
him what he was going to do as Nicholas
Winton ref and goes board by board he
says when it's over he says I've seen
the movie so it it's it's a fascinating
story about like it once it's a tragedy
that it never became put on film and at
the same time he found a way to set it
down somehow so that it still been
realized in some form as opposed to not
at all it's very interesting it deals
with that whole thing that you're
talking about like you have this thing
in your head right if you don't make it
actually get to make it
is there some other way that it can
exist or does it already exist you know
like is it already exist even in your
head is that that is that that's still
valuable or if the script just exists is
that valuable I think you you have to
you'll kill yourself you you'll kill
yourself if things that don't happen
that you think only can be realized in
this certain way and if they don't
happen that way and you've made it that
way then it can only it's only going to
be good if it gets done this way I think
you're it's a way you start chipping
away at your own spirit I think we have
to all independent filmmakers all
filmmakers have to find a way of being a
finding a way of realizing these things
that may not get made exactly as they
and I think I think this happens a lot I
think just like for example I remember I
wrote a script that I thought I was
going to direct and it was a very
interesting true crime story that I was
hired and it was interesting again it
was one of these situations where
somebody said you've worked with us
before we want to do another movie with
you but we want to do a true crime story
of like a serial killer that hasn't been
told before so I was like okay I'm not
like a serial killer like historian but
I'll come up with something and I found
an amazing story about a serial killer
whose best friend was actually the cop
investigating his crimes it was like
this fascinating story about betrayal
and it was true and I wrote this thing
and I fully expected to direct it and I
had this noir I had this elaborate
ending where the two confront each other
in a drive-in movie theater I'd always
wanted to set him a scene in a drive-in
theater I thought it was just
interesting and anyway long story short
is at the 11th hour I was removed from
directing it because they sold the
rights to the script that I had written
to another company somebody else came in
and made the movie and they made it even
in a lower budget then I would they
would wanted to and the end of the
addition to it being sort of a mess on
all levels the end of the movie which
takes place in this drive-in theater of
course takes place like in a warehouse
because that's the de-facto low budget
of course it takes place in oreal
and and then I realized that you know
four years later when I was making some
guy who kills people that there was a
room for enhancing some of these
murderous scenes and sure enough the
drive-in movie theater setting found its
way into some guy who kills people so it
may not be that's a minor thing but I
think you know if things ideas are
really important or characters or
certain shots that may have been
intended for a particular project that
didn't get made you know you owe to
yourself to try to insinuate that stuff
because really it's just stuff that
needs to come out of you as a as an
artist you're like I gotta get this out
somewhere so if it fits I'll put it here
instead of here you know it's I don't
think you want to get into what John
bought well John Boorman who directed
deliverance in Excalibur and hope and
glory he said something like this
business is a lot about all the movies
you didn't get to make and I was kind of
like wow that's a real depressing way of
looking at it because everybody has a
million projects that almost got made
that didn't but I think if you look at
it only in that way not say that Borman
only looks at it that way but if you
start to focus on that I think you'll
start to look at your career as an
artist or as a filmmaker as a failure I
don't think you should do that I think
you need to look at at what you've
accomplished and value that and not just
look at the things that didn't happen or
aren't going to happen because that's
kind of far outweigh the things that
don't happen are going to far outweigh
the things that did so I don't know more
preaching to myself at this point
because that sounds like great advice
all of us could take do do you do that I
try you know I really try I think it's
hard because you all filmmakers are
looking to do the next thing and so you
don't really take stock you tend not to
take stock of the things that you've
already done all you're looking at is
what you're trying what's in front of
you
I think that's healthy because that
means that you still have something that
you need to express and the draw it that
drives you and I definitely have that
but every once in a while I'll try to
take stock of that you know you made a
few things and a couple of these things
you're actually happy with and so when
you're feeling really low about oh this
isn't happening or no one no one likes
me or I can't get hired or why did he
get the job and not me like you you have
to I think you need to look at what
you've what you're creating what you
have created and and and value that say
hey you know what you did that and
chances are you're gonna do something
else too so it's easy it's easy for me
to sometimes fall into kind of like a
funk where you're like oh man this is a
you know this is a lull and or this is a
valley instead of a peak and you know I
think you just have to kind of look at
the whole thing it's like can't can't
just look forward because then you'll
you'll you may be denying yourself some
of your own accomplishments you know
even if you only done one thing he was
only done a short even if you only done
one short then you're trying to get your
feature made and it's like you're having
trouble and you're having trouble look
to the short that you have made or the
script that you've written maybe it's
only a script look to that as a source
of hey look I can do I've done this this
got done so it's not impossible you know
but then again most artists are not on
this like you know I don't you want to
talk about the dsm-4 spectrum or what I
don't know if it's probably outdated
book but you know most of them are on
this wild thing yes all part of our
nature is that we do have these
incredible highs and lows yeah well
maybe that's the other thing that you
they didn't answer your question earlier
about what is the 25 year old not know
who's that you know and I said this I've
answered this question before but that's
it no matter as much as you would love
it to be this constantly building
stepladder it is this crazy you know you
can you can drop like a stone and that
just does not mean that doesn't mean
that that you can't climb up again right
but that's just that was a big surprise
for me you know when those valleys came
it was like holy yeah
end of the world like I cannot believe
it and but you survived you know sure
you